foreign
I've been in law enforcement since 1993
so I'm in my 30th year this is my I'm
going into my fifth year as the sheriff
of Riverside County
and
in my career law enforcement has changed
drastically from the time I was a patrol
Deputy until today where where we find
ourselves today uh it's sometimes
unrecognizable
my name is Chad Bianco and I am the
sheriff of Riverside County
I would say that in the last 10 years
criminals have become
increasingly more violent and Brazen and
it's this is across the board this is
not just the sheriff's department this
is not police departments it's not even
the state of it's not just one isolated
place it's across the country and we are
seeing what we are seeing in in response
to these very LAX laws on on crime the
the the push to decriminalize everything
the push to lessen the penalty for
something or even take away the penalty
for crime is basically emboldening
criminals to do more it's it really is
it's common sense you can see this
happening and for for our lawmakers to
to not sit back and and think about the
the consequences of what they're doing
over you know some social agenda is it's
really horrifying for long enforcement
and it is horrifying for the public that
has to deal with it
the the brazenness and the violence of
of criminals that we are seeing today is
uh it's an interesting phenomenon
but I will tell you one major difference
from when I was a deputy back 25 years
ago 30 years ago and what we have now is
there was a there was a respect between
the criminal
and law enforcement they knew that we
were coming to get them and we were
going to arrest them and when they got
caught they got caught they knew that
they got caught and they gave up and
they suffered the consequences and as we
come to today's
point in time when we have this this
National push even from a from horrible
presidential cabinets and from from from
their administrations when when they
ridicule police and when they blame
police for things it doesn't necessarily
cause the general public to think that
but that criminal element that is uh
that is pretty much anti-law enforcement
anyway they get more emboldened they get
more they they feed off of that and what
we are seeing now when you have when you
have politicians that are that are
telling people to stand up to fight for
yourself and fight for your rights
against these cops that's what the
criminals are doing
but that hardened criminal they are
emboldened to fight with us they were
emboldened to uh to resist arrest
they're emboldened to run they're
emboldened to steal cars and not stop
when we pull them over uh we are our law
enforcement our deputies our police and
our and our deputies are are far more
likely to be involved in use of force
situations than when I was a deputy and
it's solely because of the resistance
from the people that we're trying to
arrest
we only apply Force when there is a
resistance our use of force is to some
type of resistance if there wasn't
resistance then we wouldn't apply Force
so what we are seeing now with this
emboldenment of of the criminal of the
criminal element is they just have
absolutely zero spec for people they
have zero respect for life and they have
zero respect for law enforcement so we
come in contact with them the chances
that they are going to fight with us to
in an attempt to get away are more
likely to happen than not happen